bonsoir nous sommes le mercredi 30 mars
merci de nous retrouver pour cette
nouvelle édition du 78 le journal comme
chaque jour nous revenons sur votre
actualité locale entouré de nos invités
des journalistes de la rédaction tout de
suite les titres de cette
édition ce matin une soixantaine de
migrants a été accueillis au centre
d'hébergement des mort ma à Versailles
plusôt dans la matinée ils avaient été
évacués de la station de métro
stalingrade à Paris où ils étaient
installés ils ont été pris en charge par
la
Croix-Rouge demain jeudi 31 mars
nouvelle journée de mobilisation contre
le projet de loi de travail de la
ministre Miriam elcomery les étudiants
sont attendu dans la rue pour nous en
parler ce soir nos invités deux
représentants yvelinois de syndicat
étudiants de l'UNEF et de
l'uni et enfin le département fait le
point sur ses orientations culturelles
futures une réunion avait lieu cet
après-midi dit à l'ESTACA de montiner le
Bretonneux afin d'évoquer les différents
dispositifs et projets mis en place par
le
département et installation aujourd'hui
du comité opérationnel de lutte contre
le racisme et l'antisémitisme dans le
département une structure qui permettra
de traduire sur le terrain la politique
du gouvernement dans ce domaine
éducation répression face notamment aux
23 actes répertoriés dans les ivelines
en 2015 on notera ainsi les 42
procédures engagées l'an dernier au
parquet de Versailles pour diffamation
et injure en raison en raison de la race
la religion ou encore la nation
d'origine le gouvernement entend ne
laisser aucun incident sans suite il
entend aussi former les citoyens comme
vous allez l'entendre là je vous donne
un exemple le le ministère de
l'Éducation nationale a mis en ligne un
site portail de ressources euh pour
pouvoir justement parler de ces
choses-là avec des des fiches pratiques
la laïcité comment en parler la liberté
d'expression comment en parler euh
pourquoi on dit racisme et antisémitisme
toutes ces questions-là
vous prenez un public d'âcolaire quel
que soit le lieu quel que soit le moment
ces questions sont posées donc il faut
pouvoir y répondre parce que si on y'y
répond pas avec de bonnes réponses avec
de bons outils avec des repères
historiques juridiques et autres on peut
être certain que sur les réseaux sociaux
sur Internet on va trouver des réponses
et ce sera pas toujours les bonnes et je
vous le disais en titre une soixantaine
de migrants accueillis à versaill le
centre d'hébergement d'urgence des
mortem accueilli ce matin desvigrant
évacué de la station stalingrade à Paris
ils étaient inst allit depuis environ 3
semaines dans ce campement
essentiellement soudanais éitréens et
afghan ils étaient plusieurs centaines
et une soixantaine a été pris en charge
et conduit par la Croix-Rouge des
Yvelines selon nos confrères du 78 actu
10 bénévoles de l'action sociale et une
équipe de quatre secouristes de la
Croix-Rouge étai présent pour procéder
aux premières formalités comme leur
enregistrement et leur installation et
tout autre sujet à présent cette
après-midi l'ESTACA de Montini le
bretonux a accueilli la culture dans ses
locaux ou plutôt les acteurs culturels
des in directeur de théâtre ou élus
locaux ils étaient plus d'une centaine à
assister à la présentation des
orientations culturelles du département
mené par Joséphine colmans berger
vice-présidente du conseil départemental
délégué à la culture cette réunion a
fait le point sur les différents
dispositifs mis en place par le
Département un reportage signé Camille
Lambert avec la baisse des dotations de
l'État quel avenir pour la culture dans
les Yvelines mercredi 30 mars à l'ESTACA
de Montini le Bretonneux le département
a fait une présentation de ces
orientations culturelles pour les années
à venir une réunion qui faisait suite
aux journées d'échang décembre dernier
entre élus locaux et acteurs culturels
on a dû réfléchir bien sûr pour ne pas
abandonner la culture parce que c'est
pas du tout notre principe et c'est
surtout on a très envie au contraire
d'accompagner et bien de mettre en place
des dispositifs qui sont des dispositifs
je dirais qui demandent plus de
participation plus d'échang et de
nouveautés et de remise en question
peut-être directeur de théâtre metteur
en scène et élu du territoire plus d'une
centaine de personnes ont assisté à
cette rencontre l'objectif pour le
département réaffirmer son engagement
pour la culture et présenter les
différentes solutions imaginées il a par
exemple lancé un appel à projet afin de
soutenir le développement culturel et
les initiatives les plus prometteuses la
problématique c'est simplement la
méthode aujourd'hui du partage que l'on
doit faire entre les différents
territoires pour continuer d'accompagner
la culture quand vous voyez l'État la
Région le Département les intercom
communalité et les collectivités chacun
devra retrouver une place qui est la
sienne pour pouvoir repositionner un
équilibre on est vraiment en train de
dessiner ce que sera le spectacle vivant
dans les 10 dans les 15 ans à venir pour
moi la question c'est à moyen
terme d'avoir un un paysage relativement
harmonieux sur le plan culturel après
étude des candidatures le versement de
l'aide pour les projets commencera en
septembre de nouvelles réunions auront
lieu dans les prochains mois pour
concrétiser les différents dispositifs
imaginés par le
département et nous ouvrons une page
politique à présent ils sont 11 à
s'engager dans la primaire à droite en
vue de la présidentielle de 2017 mais un
seul et pour le moment qualifié le
député yvinois Jean-Frédéric Poisson 53
ans si les autres devront trouver des
parrainages d'élus à travers toute la
France ce dernier en tant que président
du parti chrétiendémocrate n'aura pas à
répondre à cette obligation en tant que
formation autonome elle peut désigner
son candidat et n'a besoin que d'une
confirmation du bureau politique des
républicains c'est désormais chose faite
depuis hier soir et malgré ce privilège
en Frédéric poisson n'est pas tendre
avec ses adversaires on l'écoute il
était ce matin au micro de Fanny
Bourdillon je pense que l'immense
majorité des candidats qui se sont
présentés sinon tous était membrre du
gouvernement en mai 2012 lorsque nous
avons perdu les échéances
présidentielles et législatives d'une
manière ou d'une autre leur
responsabilité est engagée dans ce qui a
été notre défaite au printemps il y a 4
ans et deuxièmement le message que je
porte jusqu'ici n'a pas d'équivalent je
suis un candidat qui affirme ne pas
enfin je je ne veux pas donner plus de
droit qu'il le faut à logique de marcher
je ne suis pas libéral je ne suis pas
atlantiste je ne suis pas fédéraliste
sur le plan européen alors que tous mes
autres concurrents le sont il est temps
à présent de passer à notre entretien
demain jeudi 31 mars nouvelle journée de
mobilisation contre le projet de réforme
du Code du travail proposé par la
ministre Miriam elcomer les étudiants
moteurs dans cette mobilisation seront
dans la rue pour nous en parler ce soir
deux invités sont en plateau avec nous
Léal la Cube bonsoir vous êtes
secrétaire général de l'UNEF dans les
ivelines et Rudy mirzen bonsoir vous
êtes président de l'uni à l'UVSQ alors
il y a déjà eu deux mobilisations le
mouvement prend donc de l'ampleur c'est
la dernière mobilisation demain selon
vous
ben à à voir après ce qui est proposé
par le gouvernement je sais que au
niveau des des coordinations nationale
il y a probablement une autre date de
mobilisation qui est prévue la semaine
prochaine mais la mobilisation elle se
fait en fonction aussi de ce qui est
décidé et des évolutions qui des
évolutions qu'on peut avoir sur ce
projet de loi vous vous attendiez à un
mouvement de de telle ampleur par
rapport à ce projet de loi on attendez
vu la porortée réformatrice qu'on porte
à ce texte que évidemment des étudiants
se mobilisent donc nous on a rien contre
ça on est en démocratie le fait que des
étudiants se mobilise pour la politique
c'est une très bonne chose après c'est
évidemment pas une question de fond
c'est une question de forme nous on est
opposé à si vous voule de faire en sorte
que l'université soit pris en otage par
ça c'est dans le débat citoyen que cela
doit avoir lieu donc on ne comprend pas
les blocages même si on a pas eu à
versaill 50 an en Eveline mais dans les
autres facultés on a pu voir les
agissements à to Billac qui sont
inadmissibles justement pour faire de
l'université un lieu de savoir et de
transmission des des connaissances après
la mobilisation bonne chose ou pas
mauvaise chose ça fait partie du débat
démocratique donc à partir de là on peut
juste faire en sorte que cette
mobilisation se passe bien éviter tous
les débordements qui sont inutiles alors
pour l'UNF demain aller à cube le l'UNF
app le rassemblement au théâtre de con
vin ensuite donc au rassemblement à
Paris vous-même vous ferez partie de
cette mobilisation oui alors on organise
avec une interorganisation qui s'est
monté sur sur le VSQ une assemblée
générale à 10h30 d'abord au bâtiment
d'alambert euh où on convie tous les
étudiants à venir et c'est dans le cadre
de cette assemblée générale qu'on décide
démocratiquement euh des moyens d'action
aussi qu'on met en œuvre euh et donc
effectivement il n'y a pas eu de blocus
pour le moment qui a été voté
c'est pas c'est pas d'actualité les
étudiants se mobilisent de même il pour
le moment il y a pas besoin de il y a
même pas besoin de de bloquer l'UVSQ
pour que les étudiants se mobilisé sur
cette question et effectivement on n'
pas l'intention de prendre en otage les
étudiants qui veulent aller en cours
donc l'uni est contre le blocage mais se
mobilise quand même également c'est à la
discrétion de chacun chacun est citoyen
chacun pas de consigne chacun a le droit
d'avoir ce qu'il veut simplement c'est
que le l'uni ne comprend pas comment
est-ce qu'on apporte une si grande
importance à un texte qui n'est pas si
réformateur qui est un peu à image du
gouvernement c'estàdire des réformeses
qui avancec enans avancer qui reculent
comme avec la déchance de nationalité
qui va pas très loin donc ensemble on a
le droit de manifester pour tout on est
en France mais on ne comprend pas
l'ampleur mais on l'accepte c'est la
démocratie donc il y a aucun souci et la
vous êtes d'accord pour vous c'est une
réforme ce projet de loi de travail euh
non c'estàdire que ce projet s'inscrit
dans tout ce qui a pu avoir ces 40
dernières années on libéralise on nous
on est contre justement ce le fait
d'acter que c'est en en flexibilisant
encore les salariés en leur demandant
pe-être une une variable d'ajustement
que on va réussir à palier le chômage à
recréer du pouvoir d'achat et tout ça au
contraire donc non c'est pas c'est pas
une réforme ça ancre encore un peu plus
le tournant que que prend le
gouvernement actuellement et là au-delà
de au-delà justement comme tu le disais
des réformes sur le lo du travail sur la
déchance de nationalité on pense que là
on a vraiment on est vraiment dans un
virage sur le choix de société qu'on
fait actuellement pour la France et et
et même au niveau au niveau
supranational et donc voilà non c'est
pas une réforme et non c'est quelque
chose que on ne compte pas laisser
passer et on comprend complètement
l'ampleur des mobilisations actuelles
mer beaucoup de de jeunes d'étudiants
dans la rue disaient que voà c'était un
problème cette flexibilité du du travail
ça leur faisait peur pour vous vous
parle de réformette la problématique
c'est que qu'on le veille ou non ce code
là cette loi qu'on dit el comerie déjà
elle a été trop modifié pour elle a
perdu son sens qu'on soit pour qu'on
soit contre là on a une sous-loi
deuxièmement c'est qu'aprèsut le St il
est là c'est que c'est ce code de
travail n'est pas en vigueur et la
situation en France elle est dramatique
au niveau du du du chômage de l'emploi
et donc il y a deux possibilités soit on
décide que la situation on s'en
satisfait dans l'état actuel ce qui à
mon avis est pas possible soit on pense
qu'il faut acter le processus de
mondialisation le processus qu'on est en
compétition c'estàd accepter la
compétition telle qu'elle est c'est le
monde tel qu'il est sortir de
l'idéologie et par exemple nous en tant
que jeune on doit savoir qu'on va pas
vivre la même période que nos parents on
a une érisation de la société tu parlais
de libéralisation c'est un fait mal
malheureusement c'estàd
qu'indépendamment qu'on soit pour ou
contre c'est un mouvement qui est
mondial c'est dans le voisin allemand le
voisin espagnol les réformes italiennes
et donc c'est-à-dire que à nous de
suivre le mouvement et de faire en sorte
qu'on s'y adapte le mieux cette loi elle
elle comporte pas que de la perfection
loin de là cette loi elle va pas dans le
fond du problème c'est juste moi
j'appelle ça réformé c'est dans le sens
on propose on recule et au final il se
passera rien puisqueau final on sa tous
très bien que ce gouvernement n'a pas de
courage donc nous simplement cette loi
d' d'un point de vue elle est nécessaire
mais elle ne va pas assez loin par
exemple par simple accord on peut passer
de 10h à 2h de travail maximum par jour
je ça ça ne vous éerait pas en tant
qu'étudiant notre du travail
unelexibilité dans l'entreprise c'est
dire que les chaque entreprise est
particulière c'est un monde à part
chaque entreprise a des besoins
différents mais moi je suis salarié en
dehors de mon de mes études évidemment
que même moi je passe des accords avec
une convention collective avec mon
employeur c'est une nécessité de
s'adapter puisquen gros le but quel
est-il c'est le c'est l'emploi c'est que
tout le monde veut un emploi maintenant
le but maintenant c'est c'est plus de
trouver un CDI parce que malheureusement
on est dans une situation très précaire
au niveau de l'emploi c'est un emploi et
justement si on peut mettre un peu plus
de flexibilité pour les entreprises
c'est le PME c'est le tissu industriel
de la France tissu économique c'est elle
qui embauche mais ça ça va pas justement
précariser l'emploi selon vous d'un côté
ça va précariser l'emploi peut-être d'un
côté en favorisant les licentimements
mais si on favorise les licenciements
d'un point de vue économique on favorise
aussi l'entrée puisque les PME seront
plus rassurés de savoir qu'il y a une
possibilité de s'adapter puisqu'il faut
pas se lurer si les PME ont le carnet de
commande qui est plein elles embauchent
qu'est-ce qui les la vous vous effraiez
dans cette loi selon vous vraiment les
choses importantes à changer comment on
remplit le carnet de commande d'une PME
c'est enfin pour moi c'est aussi enfin
c'est ça fait partie d'ailleurs des
contrepropositions que qu' l'UNEF c'est
justement en redonnant du pouvoir
d'achat au salariés en leur permettant
de en leur permettant de consommer que
qu'on va pouvoir justement remplir les
les carnet de commande des PME et et
certainement pas en en disant au patron
non non mais vous pouvez embaucher parce
que vous pourrez virer plus facilement
enfin ça enfin ça non c'est pas c'est
pas acceptable et justement il y a
énormément de chômage chez les jeunes
euh tu disait que le CDI bon bah c'est
un idéal mais que on l'aurait pas je
trouve ça très très défétiste et et
justement il y a une grosse mobilisation
actuellement et c'est enfin moi je me je
me satisferais pas d'un d'un d'un CDI au
Rabet enfin non mais tu as raison mais
le problème c'est que si tu veux la
purure vision kénésianisme de l'économie
ça marche plus la relance par la
consommation ça a fait ses on a bien vu
dans les années 70 malheureusement on a
un monde tel qu'il est ultra libéral
indépendamment du du simple exemple
français ce qui fait que moi évidemment
l' absolu je préfère un CDI une
stabilité toute ma vie évidemment
maintenant il y a l'ubérisation de la
société l'économie elle évolue et tu
sais que le CDI est plus protecteur en
emagne on va recentrer le débat pour
l'uni le gouvernement donc ne va pas
assez loin qu'est-ce que vous attendez
aujourd'hui du gouvernement et bien qui
porte ses responsabilités il y a du
chiffre de chômage qui est très très
haut soit il fait des vrais réformes on
est pour on est contre mais des vraies
réformes dans lesquelles on propose un
texte on va jusqu'au bout et on ne cède
pas la pression que ça soit pour ces 10
derniers mois c'est ça avance à reculon
ça avance à recul pour l'UNF on le
retrait de la loi le Pr retrait pur et
simple il y a eu des des reculs faits
par le gouvernement notamment suite aux
mobilisations on nous menassait quand
même d'un 493 au moment où au moment où
cette où ce projet de loi est sorti pour
la faire passer en force ça a été retiré
il y a eu des suite au suite aux
manifestations il y a eu des
dispositions qui ont été enlevées pour
autant il reste encore vraiment trop de
trop de plans sur lesquels cette loi est
pas acceptable pourtant la réforme du
Code du travail c'est indispensable les
les professionnels le disent le
gouvernement dis ça aussi est-ce qu'il y
a besoin de plus de discussion dans ce
cas-là et ben là il y a eu aucune
concertation il y a aucune négociation
enfin déjà il y a aucune négociation qui
n'a été faite et il y a aucune
négociation qui soit possible cette loi
c'est clairement pas une loi qui qui a
été faite en concertation avec des
salariés c'est c'est évident vous vous
avez été reçu enfin vous personnellement
MINEF a été reçu par le Premier ministre
vous en êtes ressorti déçu justement
qu'est-ce que vous attendez pour une
prochaine étape plus de concertation
justement avec avec le gouvernement par
rapport à cette réforme ou la réforme du
COD du travail ben oui oui oui nous on
est toujours ouvert on est toujours
ouvert à la concertation et
effectivement on va tout le temps toquer
aux portes du Premier ministre euh après
après là c'est vrai qu'on n'est pas du
tout dans un objectif de négociation sur
cette loi puisque de toute façon
l'esprit même de cette loi ne nous
satisfaera pas vous êtes d'accord vous
attendez la même chose aussi de la
concertation non mais en fait justement
on parle de concertation et on dit qu'il
y a aucune concertation possible sur ce
texte c'est un petit peu contradictoire
je pense qu'on peut débattre de tout il
faut que la société elle accepte
justement l'État dans lequelle elle est
indépendamment de ce qu'on pense de la
loi de travail il faut en parler et je
pense que la négociation c'est possible
sur tous les textes calmement posément
vous comprenez bien que bon nous on la
porte pas particulièrement à cœur parce
que justement c'est une réformeette je
maintiens mais on peut négocier surtout
on peut parler calmement il y a aucun
souci quoi est-ce que selon vous la la
jeunesse est pris suffisamment en compte
par le gouvernement le président
François mouin a dit qu'il serait le
président pour les jeunes vous êtes
d'accord finalement avec ça j'ai pas
l'impression quand on parle de quand on
parle de précar ité les jeunes sont
particulièrement touchés il a quand même
25 % de taux de chôage chez les
jeunes on nous facilite pas l'entrée sur
le l'entrée dans l'emploi là c'est on va
enchaîner les CDD les stages enfin non
là là les jeunes sont clairement pas
pris en compte je voyez a qui c'est Rudy
on va aller dans un ancrage plus local
on va revenir à Saint-Quentin enine
jeudi dernier se déroul les élections
internes donc à l'université de versaill
Saint-Quentin en ieline des élections
pour renouveler les membres du conseil
d'administration et des différentes
commissions Jean-Luc vessère donc le
présid id sortant ne décroche que 20
sièges sur un total de 71 celle soutenue
par son principal opposant Didier guimau
arrive en tête avec 34 sièges pardon je
vous propose d'écouter la réaction de
Jean-Luc vessère par téléphone je peux
pas dire que les résultats me
satisfassent pleinement puisque donc je
pensais que N je pourrais faire un
meilleur score en terme d'élu alors
maintenant ce qu'on constate c'est que
les résultats ne sont pas non plus très
très clair et très très déséquilibré je
BAE pas les bras çaà dire que je pense
que euh que je peux essayer de
rassembler rassembler euh donc
évidemment les gens qui ont qui ont voté
pour moi enfin pour moi les les élus de
de mis éventuellement les élus d'autres
listes et puis dans les élus étudiants
et après il y a la question quand même
des extérieurs qui se pose aussi hein
ballotage est défavorable pour le
président sortant même si rien n'est
fait car les étudiants aussi se sont
prononcés dans d'autres commissions le
nouveau chef de fil sera désigné le 10
mai on l'a entendu lusr ne baisse pas
les bras votre réaction par rapport à ça
justement est-ce que ça va changer
beaucoup chose qu'est-ce que vous
attendez comme résultat de déjà nous
avons eu la chance de rencontrer
Jean-Luc vessère et nous allons
rencontrer bientôt monsieur guimau déjà
en fait on va voter pour le meilleur
président pour la fac on vote pas pour
la personne et le but c'est qu'on va
voter pour le président qui défendra la
professionnalisation des diplômes qui
aura le courage d'admettre la sélection
en master qui aura le courage de faire
de l'université une préparation monde du
travail donc nous attendons
véritablement l'entretien avec Monsieur
guimau Nous nous prononcerons en
connaissance de cause pour les étudiants
il y a un programme qui vous a plus
tenté pour
l'instant h on va dire que pour le
moment c'est partagé au sein même de la
section et nous attendons véritablement
les propositions concrètes hors du
programme et voilà comment ils vont
gérer la gouvernance de l'université et
à la Cube même à la lunef vous avez
rencontré donc les deux candidats voilà
votreaction par rapport justement euh
ben nous on donne pas de blancin à un
candidat en particulier voilà on attend
de voir les propositions qui seront
faites sachant que nous c'est vraiment
les étudiants qui sont qui seront au
cœur de au cœur de ce choix et et et les
intérêts des étudiants et euh et nous
sommes contre la sélection en master
donc effectivement euh c'est pas c'est
pas sur ça que que nous allons porter
notre vote mais actuellement on n pas
non plus de on n pas non plus de de
choix qui est fait vous attendez quoi de
votre nouveau président de l'université
et ben qu'il est également un certain
courage politique d'admettre que après
la crise budgétaire qu'a connu le VSQ
c'est pas possible de continuer de
continuer comme ça euh un président
également qui a le courage de de
reconnaître les failles qu'il y a dans
la commun Paris Saclay qui prend de plus
en plus d'ampleur d'ampleur pour sur le
VSQ et voilà un président qui soit au
service du droit des droits des
étudiants et et qui qui fasse des
propositions qui aillent dans ce sens
très bien merci beaucoup à vous deux
d'être venu sur notre plateau et d'avoir
répondu à notre question je le rappelle
demain journée de mobilisation on
retrouvera donc les étudiants de
l'université de Versailles 550 ans
niveline à 11h c'est ça au théâtre dev
le thâre de 550 an iveline aussi à à la
Faculté
tout autre sujet à présent parlons
d'immobilier d'entreprise grands groupes
internationaux PME et centes de
recherche ils sont nombreux à choisir
l'Île-de-France ou encore les iines pour
y développer leur activité mais que
recherchent les entreprises pour
s'installer dans la région
l'Île-de-France et saintquenttin en iine
en particulier sont-ils toujours une
région d'innovation propice aux
entrepreneurs les réponses avec Fanny
Bourillon c'est dans les locaux de
l'orie que l'on étudie le marché
immobilier d'entreprise en île-de-fance
chaque année trois études en moyenne y
sont réalisé l'Observatoire a constaté
qu'avec un parc de 53 millions de mètres
carrés de bureau l'île-de-fance est
première d'Europe mais l'offre a besoin
d'être modernisée
l'attractivité économique en en
Île-de-France aujourd'hui est un petit
peu pénalisé par l'offre de qualité
voilà donc on est plus dans le
renouvellement que dans la construction
aujourd'hui le parc est le parc de
bureau parisien est est assez obsolète
en en partie he assez obsolète donc
plutôt on est dans la modernisation du
parc qui permettra d'avoir une offre de
qualité et de pouvoir répondre aux
besoins des entreprises notamment local
mais aussi international dans les
Yvelines c'est dans les années 90 que
l'agglomération de 50 ans en Yveline
s'est affirmé comme un pôle d'affair
dynamique aujourd'hui c'est le deuxième
pôle économique de l'Ouest parisien
après la défense une preuve que
l'agglomération conserve de nombreux
atouts pour les entreprises d'abord la
proximité de la capitale puisque
Saint-Quentin est situé à 20 km de Paris
c'est aussi on l'a dit le tissu
dynamique des entreprises des des grands
noms des grandes sociétés des DPE
innovantes des laboratoires de recherche
un pôle université TR dynamique et
également des logements le développement
des transports mais aussi l'intégration
de centin en ivine au cluster Paris
saccly devrait permettre à
l'agglomération de renforcer son
attractivité dans les années à
venir retour à présent sur le trophée de
robotique qui se déroulé à saintquenttin
en Eveline le weekend dernier une
compétition qui permet aux jeunes de 7 à
18 ans de travailler en équipe et de se
familiariser avec les outils de
technologie de demain la Ferme du Manet
à Montin le brotneux accueillait la
finale régionale un reportage signé
Wilfried Richy et Camille
[Musique]
Lambert lzt 42 42 équipes à s'affronter
lors de cette 15e édition des Trophées
de robotique l'île-de-fance organisée
par Planet science une association de
vulgarisation et ce sont les
représentants d'ici les Moulineau qui
l'ont emporté9
à c'est notre 3è année et comme toutes
les années on l'a fait en Lego et cette
année on a rajouté quelques pièces en
imprimé à l'imprimante 3D et B on a tous
participé et c'est trop cool de d'être
premier quoi la compétition aura duré
près de 10h rythmée par des matchs d'à
peine quelques minutes sur le terrain
des robots téléguidés élaborés par des
jeunes élèves de primaire des collégiens
des lycéens si un cahier des charge doit
être respectée chaque équipe doit
trouver le détail qui fera la différence
cette année la thématique c'est la plage
et différentes actions doivent être
réalisé par les équipes suivant un
cahier des charges donc ce cahier des
charges est très libre les équipes
peuvent faire comme il veulent donc il
peuvent utiliser les matériaux qu'ils
souhaitent donc des legos des mécanos ou
du bois du
comme il souhaite et du moment qu'il
qu'il puisse marquer des points donc en
fonction des actions qu'ils peuvent
réaliser ils peuvent marquer plus ou
moins de points sur le podium au côté
d'ici les moulinau Savini le temple ou
encore ne surmne ces trois équipes
représenteront la région les 9 et 10
avril prochain lors de la finale
nationale dans
l'aine et comme chaque mercredi on passe
à notre chronique environnement avec M
po bonsoir Mélanie alors cette semaine
vous allez nous présenter plusieurs
rendez-vous autour du développement
durable et du jardin c'est un weekend
chargé pour les amoureux des espaces
verts et de la nature la commune de
guyancour propose tout un après-midi
autour du développement durable il y en
aura pour tous les âges et pour tous les
goûts le but sensibiliser le public
Guillan courtois et cinquantinois c'est
ce que nous explique Sonia Durand elle
est chargée de mission Développement
Durable à la commune on sensibilise les
habitants sans aucune honce de
culpabilité mais plutôt en les dans un
esprit de de de solidarité dans un
esprit éthique dans un esprit aussi de
d'amusement de joie parce que le
développement durable finalement c'est
c'est juste un nouveau mode de vie plus
confortable pour soi et pour la planète
mais dans un esprit de joie et non pas
d'inquiétude et de nombreux acteurs de
la commune seront présents pour animer
divers ateliers il y aura un goûter bio
des séances de naturopathie vous pourrez
aussi découvrir les animaux de la ferme
ou encore réaliser des décorations
naturelles avec des produits de
récupération je laisse son Duran vous
présenter le reste du programme il y
aura des ateliers autour des légumes
ancien par exemple de rampotage par les
services des espaces verts de la ville
il y aura des ateliers
de de sorties des sorties pour aller
voir les oiseaux du territoire avec la
ligue de protection des oiseaux il y
aura des ateliers autour du pain et des
céréales proposé par Guy en courour en
transition alors pour la journée du
développement durable c'est de 18 de 14h
à 18h à la Maison Théodore mono de
Guille en cours l'entrée est libre et
tout le programme est disponible sur le
site internet de la commune dont la dont
l'adresse et sur l'écran alors ce
programme c'est seulement celui de fête
du développement durable à guyancour
mais d'autres communes yvelinoises
proposent des animations autour de la
nature et c'est le cas de Mani lesamo
qui comme chaque année invite manikois
et autres amoureux de la nature à venir
lui donner un petit coup de propre le
printemps est là depuis le 20 mars et
c'est l'occasion de faire le grand
ménage alors rendez-vous au parking du
stade Jacques Anquetil et au bassin du
buisson à 9h pensez à vos gilets jaunes
et à mettre de bonnes chaussures les
gants et les sacs de ramassage seront
fournis par les organisateurs et à
Versailles c'est plutôt le jardin et la
promenade qui seront mis à l'honneur ce
weekend la cité royale ouvre à titre
exceptionnel gratuitement le Potager du
Roi avec des visites guidées durant de
jours le parvis Saint-Louis la rue du
Maréchal Joffre et la rue d'Anjou seront
le théâtre d'atelier plus de 70
exposants sont attendus avec la création
d'un jardin éphémère ou encore des jeux
olfactifs et gustatifs le programme est
complet et là aussi à retrouver sur le
site internet merci beaucoup Mélanie
c'est la fin de cette édition avant de
nous quitter c'est le point sur les
perturbations dans les transports liés
au mouvement de greffe qui aura lieu
demain seul un train sur 10 devrait en
effet circuler sur les réseaux TER et
Transilien sur la ligne N prévoir deux
trains sur trois sur la ligne u aucun
train ne circule entre la verrière et la
défense prenez donc vos précautions le
RA et le RB seront également perturbé
quelques perturbations à prévoir
également dans les métros sachez que la
grève des carperriers sur le réseau
skibus sera également reconduite tout de
suite vous retrouvez Sephora Namani pour
nouveau numéro de Kios quant à moi je
vous retrouve demain pour un nouveau
numéro du journal je vous souhaite une
excellente
soirée